I know I know my wall is not white my
desk is brown I'm shooting in 24 frames
a second take a deep breath it's all
gonna be okay in addition to this
newness Apple is also released air pods
- they announced new iPads and new Apple
watch this for springtime I'm also
getting my entire house painted so
that's that's cold spell without fitting
right now so this video is gonna be
super interesting for both of us
like where should I even put my computer
at right well I guess I'll just pause
this okay I'm back new ear pods air pots
- was announced today if you're watching
this it was March 20th but they were
announced I woke up and I was so excited
that I rolled over that was the first
thing that I saw on my phone was like 10
different peoples that did you get the
air pots I wasn't even awake yet and I
was ordering these air pods as fast as I
could you can get 50% more talk time you
can get hands-free que si R I and the
new wireless charging case is pretty
much the thing that I'm most excited
about so now there's three different
options that you guys can get for air
pods you can get the standalone basic
air pods so 159 for $1.99 you get the
wireless charging case and the new air
pause or if you want to save some money
and just get the wireless charging case
you can get that for $79 and use your
old air pods which i think is probably
one of the smartest bets because your
air pods are working perfectly fine but
it really is no point in spending over a
hundred dollars more to get new ear pods
plus the charging case so I think that's
a really great option and I'm super glad
that they have that and as soon as I get
mine in of course yes I will make a
video about it another thing that I saw
that was super exciting is there is a
speck boost in the iMac pro they now
offer 256 gigs of ram in the iMac Pro
which basically makes my 18 or one
a gig of ram for terabytes always a
drive just a completely obsolete
computer now like I don't even know how
to function and I'm joking obviously if
you can't send sarcasm I'm sorry you
guys may have also seen that they
announce new iPads they have a new iPad
air and an own iPad Mini the iPad air is
a ten point five inch iPad of course it
has the a12 Bionic chip it has 70% two
times faster graphics plus the retina
and the true tone display another
exciting thing is both the iPad air and
the iPad Mini they both will have apple
puns to support no not our pencil
support for the new Apple pencil but the
original Apple pencil because the design
of both of these is the old design this
Apple pencil has magnetic charging so
this connects to your iPad just like so
but because the old iPads have the old
design they still have the old Apple
pencil that you charge with the
Lightning port which we all know it's by
far the worst design of her but it gets
the job done and thankfully all of the
iPad pros this is incredible I've been
using my iPad so much more lately the
graphic performance has increased by 9x
where the overall performance is 3x
which is pretty significant considering
the fact that this hasn't been updated
in a really long time I mean I kind of
thought that they were gonna do away
with the iPad Mini so it's kind of
exciting that they did decide to revive
it bring it back and make it more
powerful because I think that the iPad
Mini is used in different use cases it's
used in restaurants it's used in smart
homes it's used in many different cases
not just as a tablet for you to watch
content on the price for the iPad air
for the Wi-Fi version is $4.99 and the
Wi-Fi + cellular starts at 629 the iPad
Mini starts at 399 for Wi-Fi and for
Wi-Fi and cellular it's 529 something
else that they have announced happy a
first day of spring to you guys and to
me and to all Apple watch band members
band members family by the band where
Apple watch mmm I'll get back to myself
on that one there are new springtime
Apple watch fans and I need to just show
you guys these
let me open up my screenshots it's my
favorite colors of all of these I'd have
to say is the papaya the spearmint the
lilac I'm such a huge fan of the sport
loops I never use these until fairly
recently and it's really really really
really great I was so into the sport
bands for the longest time that that was
all I wore I only wore like the Nike
sport bands and then the first time that
I tried the sport loop it really is
perfect for working out and doing
activities I do a lot of hot yoga which
let me just tell you these can get super
disgusting after those classes I just
throw this thing in the wash like I
throw it in the washing machine but then
there's this really fun game that I have
to play with it's like where did my
Apple watch pan to get stuck to like
it's a process to find it I don't think
that you should throw them in the dryer
but I have been usually just because I
forget about it so far so good and I do
it all the time this is uh that's it
that was some of the latest news I
really I'm just making this video
because I needed to test out my lighting
I need to test out my audio and
obviously the audio probably wasn't I'm
working on a lot of really fun things
I'm redoing my office I'm redoing my set
I'm redoing so many different things I
feel like for the past year there's been
a lot of stuff going on and especially
like recently like in my personal life
and things like that so I've just been
dealing with a lot of stuff so I just
wanted to say thank you guys for always
being there and thanks for watching my
videos and it really does mean a lot to
me and I'm looking forward to some of
the fun changes hopefully here on my
channel and around me let me know what
you guys think of the set if you guys
have any suggestions feel free to let me
know a bunch of my members if you guys
are not a member already feel free to
click join or don't you don't have to it
is a paid thing but it's been really fun
because I actually let them see this set
first and this is the background that
they ended up choosing I had a bunch of
different lighting setups holds really
three that I ended up letting them see
this was their favorite so a huge thank
you to the IJ army members because you
guys really did help me pick this
because I didn't know which one I like
the best also thank you guys so much for
all the birthday wishes oh my goodness I
could not have had a better birthday
with all of your well wishes and all of
these Apple announcements like come on
now this is super exciting
you
[Music]